courage bein northumberland part of a
region with a rich history of coal
mining evidence even on the beach but
campaigners thought it was an industry
consigned to the past and want to know
why the government is considering
granting permission for a new coal mine
a kilometer from the dunes this has been
a long fight it's been seven years since
Lynn Taitt first received brochures from
the mining company a tell Co of a story
that they're going to make this
fantastic coal mine she's frustrated
that new coal mines could be opened in
Britain even though a climate emergency
has been declared I've got grandchildren
in this area and I don't want to see
them affect it any more than for
happening at the moment we need to get
our emissions down and we don't do that
what future has our children and
grandchildren got the original planning
application to build a coal mine here
went in back in 2015 in March 2018 the
then Community Secretary Sajid Javid
turned down the application raising
concerns about climate change the case
went to appeal and is now back in the
hands of the government with a decision
yet to be made during the first three
quarters of 2019 less than 2% of
Britain's electricity was generated
using coal the government plans to phase
out coal-fired power stations by 2025
there is still a domestic demand for
coal in industries such as steel cement
and even heritage railways in 2018
Britain imported just over 10 million
tons of coal which accounted for 80% of
the country's coal usage nearly half
came from Russia
coal is also imported from America
Australia and Colombia the company which
wants to open the mine already run
there's a number of sites including
nearby chaton coal is the most carbon
intensive fossil fuel you can burn but
banks mining argues if Britain is using
coal it's better to use a local coal
however banks refuses to guarantee it
won't export any of what it digs up
isn't a reality of the situation
that you desperately need to dig out
what call you can before the government
gets its strategy together to make
britain carbon neutral by 2050 we agree
that the government are moving towards
carbon neutral by 2050 and we're part of
that transition we believe that entirely
but at this present time and for the
next next few years at least we are
looking at in need of five to six
million tons of coal in the UK and if
that need is met by UK businesses it is
far better for the environment than it
is importing it from abroad which is
worse for the climate but this is
disputed by Phil Taylor who was the
chief energy witness who gave evidence
at a public inquiry if we don't open
druish be a coal mine then we're not
adding additional emissions from coal so
at some point you've got to stop opening
coal mines and keep it in the ground the
government if it really is declaring a
climate emergency and really wants to
hit Net Zero by 2050 or earlier have to
say no to a commercial project that is
in direct conflict with dealing with
climate change campaigners in George Bay
say they've waited long enough for the
government to decide how coal will
factor in its policies to tackle climate
change Lisa Holland Sky News
Northumberland